a rogue class of 100 percent of the
page-width
well this seems pretty necessary because
we want each row of columns to take up
as much base as they can so we will
check that off because we need it that
means that we won't need a row of 1/12
of the page width because we're gonna
cut up the row into columns are we only
going to need a column of 1/12 of the
page width no in fact we're going to
need columns of everything between 1 12
and 12 over 12 page widths by defining
columns for any size between 1 over 12
and 12 over 12 page widths we'll be able
to create content in columns that takes
up as much or as little of the grid as
we'd like
this means that of course this last
answer can't be right because only
creating these three classes won't give
us enough flexibility it's worth noting
that the fraction 1 over 12 is
equivalent to 8.33% 2 over 12 is equal
to sixteen point six six percent and so
on all the way up to 12 over 12 being
equal to 100% you'll be using these
numbers soon